eu quero começar trazendo uma reflexão
como que a gente como eu cheguei aqui né
é eu gostaria de perguntar como que
existe imagino mundo no mundo que a
gente vive hoje que é extremamente
machista mas com quem imagina se o mundo
fosse um espaço onde as mulheres não
fossem julgadas por serem mulheres onde
as mulheres pudessem denunciar por
exemplo um tipo de violência sem serem
questionados se apanharam porque
mereceram o que fizeram pra apanhar
se a gente por exemplo pudesse escolher
a roupa que a gente quisesse para andar
na rua sem ser exagerado
se a gente pudesse chegar em casa à hora
que a gente quisesse sem andar com medo
na rua de ser estuprada e se a gente
fosse estuprada
se a gente conseguisse chegar à
delegacia sei que a primeira pergunta
fosse mas porque estava na rua àquela
hora que roupa que estava usando você
bebeu
a gente fica pensando o tempo todo
quando viver num mundo aonde patriarcado
o machismo se fortalecem a cada dia mais
especialmente no mundo onde o machismo
patriarcado fortalecidos exatamente por
criarem disputa em amizade e rivalidade
de mulheres como a gente consegue viver
o mundo aonde a primeira pessoa nos
apoiar em tudo que a gente escolhe
normalmente uma mulher mas na hora da
dor da dificuldade a gente julga os a
mulher
a gente pensa o tempo todo que a gente
vai fazer revolução mas essa revolução
ela não pode começar e não vai começar
só não fui na perspectiva feminista de
união das mulheres e é isso que o
feminismo prega a gente não odeia homens
pelo contrário a gente convive com isso
né
convivi 11 com um a mais o que a gente
está dizendo é que a gente precisa como
os homens fazem se une a gente precisa
se unir para se fortalecer e fortalece
as outras
a gente precisa entender o nosso papel
no mundo ea nossa possibilidade no mundo
todas as vezes que eles começam um
relacionamento é engraçado porque sempre
são flores na tumba lindo amor aquela
coisa maravilhosa mas aí o cara chega
pra vocês assim então repare é porque
repare muito maior urgência
repare eu não falou hoje enfim escreva
tap mas enfim
e ele dizer se repare nega porque baiano
repare mega nem é esse é louca
nossa esse problema na ti camisa uma
pessoa desequilibrada e o que você diz a
e deve ser né amor tô com você te amo
quero ficar para o resto da vida
você já conseguiu pensar que se a ideli
é louca que vai ser a próxima luca é
você nega
então repare se a gente não consegue
entender que essa criatura é abusiva com
a está com você falando mal das que têm
algum problema com ele não é com ele
a gente não consegue construir
sociedades em patriarcado e sem machismo
e aí quero trazer uma história real que
aconteceu na vida enfim de duas mulheres
que são enfim participação da minha vida
e essas duas mulheres me mostraram o
quanto é importante a gente pensar no
feminino prático na sonoridade prática
que é uma palavra que será utilizado
muito recentemente uma mulher chegou pra
gente pedindo ajuda em razão de uma
situação de violência e ela ea gente
perguntou ela você tem testemunha para
esse processo e ela fez tenho e ele
perguntou quem é testemunha do processo
a ideli nossa parte pensa gente elas se
uniram contra embu se só isso que
aconteceu
esse menino vai auxiliar isso é o mínimo
é falar um palavrão na bahia não é vigor
mas o feminismo e aí quando isso
aconteceu foi muito louco pra gente que
está na prática do feminismo cotidiano a
gente entender que aquilo era real e que
é possível que de fato aquilo estava
acontecendo era uma mulher quando a
outra entendendo que o cara que estava
errado
isso foi fantástico e aí eu trago a
experiência neckel foi o motivo que eu
vim pra cá protec que agora estamos
juntos até ajuda nasceu há dois anos
atrás
lá em salvador ii nasceu a partir de um
post que eu fiz de uma outra campanha
que existia se chama hashtag mas há
muito em nós
essa campanha nasceu a partir de uma
jornalista baiana negra só isso aí quem
tem o nome dela e ela criou mali
de coisas que você faz todos os dias da
sua vida quem aqui nunca teve a mãe que
foi no mercado comprar uma coisa deixa
você com andrezinho sabe que fazem
coisas simples da vida
e aí que aconteceu ela fez uma lista de
coisas que ela podia ajudar outras
mulheres ela botou gente eu posso te
ensinar a da eu posso ensinar a andar de
bicicleta eu posso ajudar escreveu um
projeto social eu posso ficar com seu
filho pra você resolver qualquer
problema que você precise
após lançar seu cabelo enfim tudo isso
de graça e no final a hashtag mais uma
entre nós quando vi aquele poxa é
incrível diz assim velho vou passar meu
cabelo
vocês acharam gerrard - não há outra
saída - fui cruzar o cabelo eu já
conhecia sua edições maravilhosa e aí eu
tava no momento que eu gosto de dizer
que não era e foi no astral
por que deixar passar o aniversário mas
era um momento de muita aflição assim eu
estava desempregada eu estava sem grana
mesmo assim já acabado de me mudar para
um apartamento muito pequeno se desfazer
de metade dos meus móveis e tava enfim
no tacho assim sem um real para raspar o
dia nem dinheiro para raspar e ficou
brincando que às vezes leva a minha
filha na escola andando às vezes eu ia
para o fórum de mulheres andando porque
não tinha grana em transportes informou
muito mais difícil da minha vida e foi
um momento que quando foi lançado e
acabou com sua idade ela fez assembléia
seria incrível se a gente conseguisse
profissionais liberais para poder também
atender a partir dessa lógica de
oferecer de forma gratuita
efe assim a isso eu vou fazer o curso e
aí na casa dela fiz o curso posso
advogar para uma mulher por mês que
estejam em situação de violência ou que
precise de um advogado na área de
família porque era um número não deixa
que a violência é o cara que não paga
pensão e também violento o cara que não
dar o divórcio a mulher não partilha de
bens e também violento e aí esse post ea
casa da amiga dela 15 minutos andando
assim bem pertinho cara quando cheguei
em casa foi um negócio enlouquecedor
porque eu não consegui administrar
passar o final de semana inteiro
respondeu à mensagem e várias menções a
face oculta e várias pessoas adicionam
adicionando compartilhando me marcando
pessoas para falarem comigo e foi uma
coisa louca assim ea partir dali daquele
poxa eu comecei a entender por que a
gente é muito feminina a gente sabe
disso mas eu comecei a entender o que
era a dificuldade das mulheres em
situação de violência acessarem a
justiça sem julgamento todas as vezes
que a mulher
na delegacia e disse eu quero prestar
queixa porque eu fui agredida
todas as vezes vai haver alguém que vai
dizer assim é porque ele bateu o que
você fez para ele bater
e aí eu comecei a entender que era
necessário ouvir essa mulher de uma
forma diferenciada
quando fiz o post não tinha dimensão do
que acontecer de verdade assim não tinha
eu já era uma rede social mas não tinha
dimensão do que aconteceu exatamente uma
lacuna do sistema o acesso à justiça é
algo extremamente restrito neste país e
quando fez isso eu conheci outras duas
advogadas também feministas que
acreditavam nesse projeto
a gente se une isso foi em abril de 2016
e no dia 12 de maio de 2016 a gente cria
no facebook a página já estamos juntos é
louco porque quando a gente criou na
primeira semana deste ano 2000 curtidas
na segunda semana cinco mil curtidas na
terceira semana de maio aconteceu o
estupro coletivo da menina no rio de
janeiro que foi extremamente impactante
para cada uma de nós mulheres e quando
aquilo aconteceu eu estava no rio grande
do sul no evento e estava voltando para
salvador e fiz um post
depois desse post a gente passou de 5
mil curtidas para 65 mil curtidas e
significa dizer que não são pessoas
curtindo a página são mulheres
acreditando no projeto mulheres
acreditando que existem outras mulheres
que não mudam vielas acreditar nelas e
não julgar elas não acha que seja
extremamente feminina de sonoridade de
acolhimento de amparo de ajuda real e
isso nos trouxe óbvio inúmeras demandas
hoje a gente nasceu em salvador e hoje a
gente as nacional consultiva jurídica
mas a gente está em 23 estados do brasil
e todas as nossas as pessoas que estão
lá estão juntas são sempre mulheres nem
a gente só tem voluntários mulheres
todas elas são voluntárias e não recebem
um real eu brinco que na verdade a gente
investe nem a gente investe no futuro
tenho um filho de cinco anos então é
óbvio que quando eu pago o transporte
para ir à audiência paga o transporte
para ir podem ou ficar um dia inteiro
trabalhando e ajudando essas mulheres
estão investindo em mim na minha filha
os meus netos no futuro das mulheres
quando a gente conquista direito a gente
não conquista só aceitam conquista pra
gente a gente conquista para as próximas
gerações
em 8 de março de 1857 quando aquelas
mulheres morreram numa fábrica elas não
morrerão sabendo que os direitos seriam
delas mas elas morreram sabendo que ela
estava conquistando o direito para as
próximas gerações lutar pelo feminismo e
lutar por direitos sociais direitos
humanos é lutar por nós mas
especialmente pelos outros
eu acho que isso é mais incrível estamos
juntos eu entendi que é assustador como
existem mulheres precisamos de ajuda
como existem mulheres dão bandos de nós
ajuda amparo por ausência do estado mas
também é incrível saber que um monte de
mulher que podia tá fazendo inúmeras
coisas advogando direito tributário
ficando rica além do direito
previdenciário o dia do aposentado
mas enfim não quero julgar ninguém mas
né
mas é incrível como essas mulheres
escolheram ajudar outras mulheres
é incrível como ele faz reunião por
exemplo que a gente sempre faz a união
ea gente está ali passar horas debatendo
sobre caso discutindo sobre as histórias
entendendo o quanto a gente está mudando
a realidade da vida das pessoas
quando a gente passa o final de semana
atendendo mulheres e as mulheres mandam
mensagem a gente corre lima delegado e
faz as coisas porque a gente acredita
naquilo ea gente faz não por dinheiro
não para aparecer mas porque a gente
acredita que se a gente fizer a nossa
parte se a gente fazendo tá difícil a
gente não fizesse isso é acreditar
verdadeiramente que cada um fazendo a
sua parte cada uma contribuindo do seu
jeito a gente vai conseguir transformar
a sociedade e é isso que eu queria falar
estamos juntas mas eu quero falar de mim
né online é para além de advogar a
feminista para além de serviço nomes
sociais direitos humanos
ora se constrói se foge à parte
exatamente disso de entender o que é o
papel da mulher na sociedade é entender
que para além de tudo isso eu sou filha
de uma mãe preta eu sou mãe de uma
criança preta que entende as
peculiaridades dessa vida que entende
que é preciso fazer a luta pelo
feminismo porque o brinquedo não tem
gênero e todas as vezes que dizem a
minha filha que aquele boneco que ela
carrega é um boneco de menino é por isso
que eu luto contra todas as vezes que
minha filha usa azul e dizem que a zona
é coisa de menina
é por isso que eu luto eu luto para que
as pessoas entendam que corram
engenheiro no brinquedo não tem gênero e
se a gente não comece a jogar para o
enfrentamento da violência com o
processo de prevenção com as nossas
crianças
nada disso vai valer a pena nada disso
vai ser suficiente
e aí eu quero verdadeiramente é trazer
todas as mulheres que estão aqui nessa
platéia que eu não estou vendo todas
nessa luz mas eu sei que são muitas
eu quero trazer vocês pra luta eu quero
que vocês entendam a necessidade de
vocês entenderem que o feminismo faz
parte da nossa história
se vocês me dizem que vocês não são
feministas
vocês precisam entender que até pra
dizer que vocês não são feministas
feminismo que conquistou isso pra você
está é negá tá achando que você escolheu
acordos não sou feminista não meu amo
você dizer isso a gente no tornozelo
direito inclusive essa besteira dessa
loucura
efe destaque para julgar mas acho um
absurdo essa medida mas o que a gente
quer dizer o seguinte é que o familismo
se constrói de mãos e braços
a gente não constrói nada só quero que
vocês entendam que se vocês hoje estão
aqui ouvindo essas palestras se vocês
estão aqui se inscreveram para isso pra
fazer pra participar desta palestra
muita gente veio antes muita mulher veio
antes muita mulher morreu antes para que
a gente tivesse lei maria da penha
tivesse direito ao voto que a gente vai
sair feminicídio que a gente tivesse
direito a ter direitos que a gente
estivesse minimamente o direito à
dignidade à vida que a gente pudesse
dizer o que a gente quer que a gente não
quer que eles pudessem fazer escolhas
que a gente pudesse escolher os caminhos
que a gente queria treinar fazer a
escolha pelo feminismo não é só papel
das mulheres mas é também o papel dos
homens porque quando a gente fala do
feminismo os homens acham que a gente
pode me enche de otimismo me isenta né
feminazi a gente é tudo mas a gente
precisa entender que o machismo também
não sirvo para homens
o machismo ele também é nociva para os
homens quando diz aos homens que eles
não podem escolher determinada cor de
roupa que eles não podem brincar com
determinado brinquedo que eles precisam
ser pegar 12 eles não são aceitos que
eles são bebedores
pegar as mulheres de tal forma a gente
precisa entender que a luta ela precisa
coletiva e eu preciso dizer os homens
que eles são machistas porque é por
causa deles que estão na rua todos os
dias dizendo às pessoas que não se pode
matar mulheres pela condição das
mulheres não é possível agredir mulheres
e quando a mulher de césar não é não
não é charminho não é aquela coisa doce
não é isso a gente está falando sério
porque os nossos corpos eles precisam
ser nossos
a gente precisa ter direito aos nossos
corpos e aí o que eu quero dizer é que
eu conclamo a luta mulheres e homens
para que a gente entenda a necessidade
de fazer revolução e essa revolução ela
precisa ser feminista porque todos os
dias uma mulher estuprada a cada 11
minutos uma mulher é morta assassinada
por um homem a cada uma hora e meia
503 mulheres são agredidas por hora no
brasil
esses são números de brasil significa
dizer que qualquer um de nós pode ser a
próxima vítima
o machismo não escolhe as 16 mulheres
que vão reunir no final desse dia
pode ser qualquer um de nós assim como o
machismo não escolhe a mulher que vai
ser estuprada hoje ou daqui 11 minutos
o machismo estuprar mulheres o machismo
mata mulheres o machismo determina a
onde esse corpo pode ir e que esse corpo
não é nosso que a gente possa entender
que a luta é coletiva que a luta de cada
um de nós que a gente jogue - a coisa
mais amparo e mais entenda e se coloque
no outro o exercício da empatia é um
exercício do respeito à diversidade
a gente precisa viver na sociedade
melhor pra nós pelas outras e pelos
outros para que a gente possa de fato
andar na rua sem ser julgada pela roupa
pelo tipo de cabelo pela cor da pele
pela orientação sexual religião que a
gente possa viver num mundo onde não
haja violação de direitos humanos
era isso que eu queria trazer para vocês
estamos juntas
[Aplausos]
[Música]